[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANOJ SHARMA: I love that video.
It tells you in 30 seconds what
this whole session is about.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Manoj Sharma, and I lead
the VMware Product Management
team in Google Cloud.
And I'm really happy to be
here, and let's get going.
Today in the session,
we learn the problems
that enterprises face when they
look to transform to the cloud.
We'll see how
Google is addressing
this problem through our new
offering called VMware engine.
We'll also get a
look at the scenarios
where the service helps
to solve these problems.
And then we'll
take a deeper look
into how various Google
Cloud services can improve
the way you consume VMware.
So by now, we all understand
the benefits of the cloud,
including the innovation and
the agility it can bring.
And we've understood
this for years now.
But when we look at the report
card of cloud transformation,
we find that most applications
are still on-premises.
And so we're
wondering, why is that?
We spoke to hundreds of
customers to find out why.
And we heard that companies
often find cloud transformation
projects to be more
expensive, time-consuming,
and disruptive to operations
than what they originally
thought.
So we sat down with
them to understand
why that is the case.
And we learned that
it's not that obvious.
If you're writing
a new application,
then the cloud has a
great set of tools,
and solutions to
help you build it.
But what if it's
an existing app?
Oftentimes the app is
written by someone else
or it's a third-party app.
And keep in mind, it's
not just about running
the application or the VM.
IT does a lot more
with the application
than just let it run.
It creates business
continuity through backup
and DR. It creates
operations support
through monitoring and logging.
And it has to meet audit
and compliance requirements.
So to summarize, we realize that
the key reason cloud adoption
is slow is that IT needs to
solve the problem holistically
and not just get a platform
to run applications.
And when we look inside IT, the
largest on-premises IT platform
is VMware, used by
over 500,000 users.
And it runs over 55 million
virtual machines worldwide.
And Google and
VMware recognized,
as you saw earlier in the
video, that they can not only
help their customers
transform to the cloud,
but also accelerate and
simplify the transformation
by partnering.
And so we announced our
partnership late last year
to make VMware a first-class
citizen of Google Cloud.
And that's the
theme you will see
throughout this presentation.
It's a theme of partnership,
a theme of complementarity,
and how one makes
the other better.
We'll see how you can get
the best VMware experience
on the planet on Google Cloud.
And what better way
to describe what we
are doing than to see a demo.
And now we're going
to put on the hat
of an IT administrator looking
to run VMware on Google Cloud.
Because let's say,
for example, you
have run out of
capacity on-premises.
So let's take a look.
So you've come to the Google
Cloud console to run VMware.
You can get access
to the console
by clicking on
VMware Engine, which
allows you to not only
create a VMware environment,
but also perform common setup
and management functions.
So let's go ahead and create
a VMware private cloud.
A private cloud is a
dedicated private capacity
running on Google Bare
Metals and on Google Cloud
Locations operated by Google.
You get hyperconverged
nodes that give you
high levels of VM density.
You can choose how
many nodes you want
in your initial environment.
You can always change this
later, as we shall see.
You allocate a network
space for this environment.
And that's it.
Four simple clicks
and you can go ahead
and create a new VMware
environment in the cloud.
What you'll find is that
the service gives you
the fastest VMware
experience from the time you
click to the time you
consume the VMware.
It just takes 30 to 40 minutes.
The environment is very
compatible with how you
consume VMware on-prem as well.
It runs a fully redundant
100 gigs of networking,
giving you four lines of
availability in a single site.
And you can consume VMware
in a very cloud-like fashion.
So let's say I miscalculated
my initial capacity.
Well, not a problem--
I can go ahead and expand my
environment by adding nodes.
And this takes a matter
of minutes in the cloud
compared to much longer doing
the same thing on-premises.
Now, the service
includes all networking
necessary to run VMware.
It has a bunch of
service features
to enable VM networking,
including subnet views that
allows you to see all your
management work, your networks.
You can always create
firewalls to segment
and secure your environment.
In this interface, I'm
creating a firewall rule.
The interface is very
simple and flexible
to capture all the
common options.
You can also, once you've
done this security procedure,
allocate public IPs.
And the public IP
allocation might be
to a desktop or a web server.
And it's an action
that's instant.
And this kind of
activity would normally
take much longer on-premises.
You can also create
site-to-site VPN devices
to get out of band
management support.
Now, my VMware environment is
fully integrated with Google
Cloud Networking so that I
can connect to on-premises
to other VMs and
Google Cloud Services
directly and natively
over the cloud fabric.
I can even control
policies, such as this
allowing network egress from
the VMware cloud environment.
And so it's a very flexible
and complete network interface.
Now, the service also comes
with a lot of enterprise
manageability features.
I can see alerts for any
important changes happening
in the environment.
I can see all activity
being performed
by various users in the system.
And I can get a log
of all such actions.
And I can see a bird's
eye view of the account,
as well as other
users in the system.
Now, let's do the
most common action
expected in the
environment, which is
to access the VMware interface.
To do that, I just go
to a private cloud.
And I can access the
vSphere UI from that cloud,
which is my familiar and
common VMware interface.
I can now use that interface
to deploy workloads
and configure policies
or migrate workloads
from on-premises onto
this environment.
Are the platforms fully
integrated with Google Cloud,
as I mentioned?
Not only do I use my
Google Cloud identities
to do what I just did, but I can
also configure my environment
to live inside VPC subnets.
And I can therefore,
essentially,
get a view of my networking
across my public cloud, so
other public cloud
services and VMware.
And I can also see my
consumption and billing
in one place in the
console, alongside all
the other consumption that
I'm doing in this context.
And what's more, I also
get end-to-end support
for this service from Google.
And whether it's a VMware
problem, or a Google Cloud
problem, the service will
address that for you.
So now let's go ahead
and put this in context.
When you think about
cloud transformation,
you need to think about
the amount of change
you're making to
your deployment.
Are you changing
or creating an app
with modern application design?
Or are you also changing
IP processes around that
and creating new ones?
If you're changing both the
IT and the app architectures,
or if you're developing
greenfield apps,
you can go directly
to the cloud native
designs using Kubernetes or
the various other application
platform services that
exist in Google Cloud.
But if you're keeping the
app as is inside the VM,
you can deploy the VM
directly into the cloud.
This implies, of course,
you're changing IT
and set of new
procedures for, let's
say, backup or monitoring.
However, if you don't have
the luxury of changing either,
then you can go directly
into the VMware deployment,
as I just showed you, from
your on-premise VMware using
VMware Engine.
So let's summarize.
What do you get when
you consume the service?
You get dedicated,
isolated infrastructure
running on physical
bare metal nodes.
It also includes all
the networking required.
It includes the private
distributed storage that's
necessary to consume VMware.
You get high levels
of RAM, as well as
storage to meet your application
resource needs on the latest
gear, all flash NVMe
devices for storage.
You get 100 gigabits of
non-oversubscribed fully
redundant network designs.
And in the VMware
stack, the service
takes care of all
lifecycle management,
including upgrades
and failure handling.
And the service,
as I mentioned, is
fully integrated from a
networking standpoint,
from a billing standpoint, from
an identity standpoint, as well
as an end-to-end
support standpoint.
So what are the benefits
of all these features
and capabilities?
Now, in talking with
customers, two factors
stood out as key impediments in
performing cloud transformation
and cloud migrations.
The first is, of
course, that there
is a lot of overhead
in migration
if you want to change the app
or you change the IT as we saw.
The other is the implications,
the cost implications
of doing these kinds of changes,
the retraining that you need.
And all of this results
in a substantial slowdown
and a substantial risk to
your business in many cases.
And as you can see, VMware
Engine solves these problems.
The ease of migration,
there's no change to your VM
or your app required.
You can migrate those
applications directly
and maintain your continuity.
There's no retooling required.
You use the exact same tools
for business continuity
and operations and
security and networking
as you do on-premises.
But the service helps you
substantially lower your costs.
Since the environment
is a dedicated cloud,
you do not have to allocate
CPU resources 100% to your VMs.
All workloads do not
[? bus ?] together.
And the workloads are all
pooled into an environment
that's dedicated to you.
So you can use the
VMware platforms
or commit capabilities to
improve the workload density.
And this lowers cost.
Plus the fact that you can match
your demand and your capacity
by allocating capacity
only as much as you
need, rather than
provisioning it
for peak, that also helps
to keep the costs low.
And with the Google Cloud
efficiencies and economies
of scale, you can expect the
benefits to be passed on to you
through lower costs
in the service.
Not to mention, of course,
the Google Cloud Security,
the self-service, and automated
consumption that also improves
your efficiency and agility, and
the various innovative services
that we learn more
about subsequently
in this presentation, and
so all of these benefits
keep adding up to the initial
benefits of migration and easy
cloud transformation.
So when should you
think about the service?
The first and foremost kind
of scenario that we see
is a capacity event, such
as a data center reaching
the end of the lease
or a hardware farm
that needs a refresh.
So that's a scenario where
you would need more capacity.
And that's a good reason
to think about running
VMware in Google Cloud.
When you'd like to set up a
new DR environment, that's
another good example,
rather than go out and get
another data center stood
up and pay the extra cost.
Or for example, if you have
multiple VR environments,
you want to consolidate
them and reduce costs
once again, that's a good reason
to consider DR to VMware Engine
from your on-premise or your
leased data center VMware.
Now, due to the private
dedicated nature
and with the high-end
infrastructure, the NVMe,
the 100 gigs of networking
we talked about,
you can get really high
levels of performance
for your performance-sensitive
and latency-sensitive
workloads.
These could be
transactional workloads,
operational workloads, real-time
analytics, high performance
computing, and so forth.
Now, the VMware stack has
advanced and powerful VDI
infrastructure.
And in today's
work-from-home contexts,
you can very easily
expand to take advantage
of the cloud capacity and
agility for your desktop needs
and remote worker needs.
Now, the service is
not just about getting
VMware in the cloud
and stopping there.
You want to take advantage
of Cloud Services,
of new application
architectures,
of the innovation of
Google Cloud Services.
You can develop new
apps in GKE and Anthos,
for example, which can reach
back into the databases that
are running on VMware.
Or you can use services,
such as BigQuery,
to transform your data
or data warehousing,
or supercharge your analytics
through AI and ML services
that Google Cloud offers.
And we'll see some examples.
Now, our service
has been in preview
with many customers over
the last few months.
Deutsche Borse Group is
a marketplace organizer
for the trading of shares
and other securities.
And it is a transaction
services provider
in the financial markets.
They found that the instant
provisioning, the ability
to get a new VMware
environment in a few minutes
is very compelling as it
brings a new level of agility
to their IT.
QAD Incorporated is
a software company
that provides
enterprise resource
planning software
and related software
for manufacturing companies.
They found that the automated
deploy, the upgrade,
the failure handling,
and the easy DR
frees them from
infrastructure dependencies
and helps them focus on the
consumption and the workload
delivery.
So one of the questions
I very often get is,
can I just bring VMware, or
can I bring everything else
that I do on top of that?
How can I make my VMware
consumption better
in the cloud?
The answer is, we offer a fully
compatible VMware experience,
so you can bring your existing
tools and processes as is.
You can bring VMware first-party
tools for operations management
for VR, for large scale
infrastructure management
through vRealize Automation
and vCloud Director.
You can also take advantage
of the VMware ecosystem
of technology providers in
those spaces of backup, business
continuity, DR, monitoring,
security, networking,
and so forth.
In addition, you can take
advantage of Google Cloud
Services, which can improve the
way you monitor VMware, as well
as the rest of
your applications,
the way you back up, the way
you do application development,
the way you can do warehousing.
And I'm going to give a very
concrete and specific examples
of all of these in
subsequent slides.
In addition, third
parties are building
support for Google Cloud.
NetApp is a partner that
offers native support
for their storage
platform, which is
integrated with Google Cloud.
And it enables use cases, such
as DR, data movement, and also
workload storage.
So I've talked
about some examples.
Now let's double-click into
how Google Cloud can actually
supercharge VMware
consumption by looking
at some examples of
service integrations.
So once you have your
VMware environment up
and running in Google
Cloud, a key question is,
how do you enable
data protection
for production workloads?
Backup is the most common
way to achieve that.
The good news is that, since the
service offers a native VMware
platform, it is fully compatible
with your existing VMware-based
backup tools, so you
can get into production
quickly with no change.
However, in the cloud,
you can do better.
In your on-premise
deployments, you often
have secondary storage,
which are lower cost storage
environments to store backups.
However, to ensure that you can
survive local site failures,
you often have to do offsite
backups into paid drives,
through paid drives, or
perhaps into the cloud.
But now that your VMware
is literally in the cloud,
there is no need to
make expensive copies
and to ship data out
to multiple locations
to get better availability
and disaster resiliency.
You can back up your
data into Cloud Storage
and choose how quickly you want
to restore your data, as well
as the redundancy level
of your storage backups.
So for example, you
can choose to have
your data stored in
nearline storage,
and select
geo-redundancy to ensure
that you can survive a single
site failure at an extremely
low price point.
Thus you can get better recovery
times, better availability,
and at much lower cost compared
to your on-premise backup
infrastructure.
Now, your VMware infrastructure
has production workloads,
databases, and line of
business applications.
As you look to modernize
this infrastructure,
you want to take
advantage of technologies
like containers and Kubernetes.
Well, Anthos lets you build and
manage container-based, hybrid,
and multicloud applications.
You develop once and
run these applications
across your existing
on-premises infrastructure
or any major public
cloud provider.
Using Anthos, you can run these
applications on VMware Engine
as well.
Some of the benefits
of doing this
is that you get a dedicated
private environment
with the latest hardware,
100 gigs of networking.
Your workloads can be
right next to the databases
for the lowest latency
and best performance.
And since your environment
is single tenant,
you get the benefits
of the privacy
and the security of
dedicated [INAUDIBLE]..
Now, as you consume
VMware in the cloud,
you also want to ensure that
you avoid the screen swivel
for operations management.
For example, if you have
a performance problem,
you want to troubleshoot all
aspects of the application
dependencies in one
place, rather than
go to different systems to solve
different parts of the problem.
While the VMware
Engine fully supports
existing VMware monitoring and
logging tools without changes,
as you start to develop hybrid
applications, for example,
using Anthos that partially
might live outside of VMware,
getting all of your
operations data in one place
is going to be important.
To solve this problem, you can
use Google Cloud Operations--
formerly it was known
as Stackdriver--
to collect metrics, logs, traces
across VMware Engine, as well
as other Google Cloud Services.
You can then use the built-in
out-of-the-box dashboards
to view and monitor the
platform and applications.
And you can then query
and analyze these signals
intelligently.
And you can see information
from the platform,
from vCenter, from ESXi,
and you can do log analysis.
There's no agent required.
And in fact, VM level data, CPU,
memory, disk, and network usage
is all included, all
available as part
of the signals that come
from the VMware platform
without having to install any
agents inside the workloads
themselves, the VMs themselves.
But if you so want,
you want a deeper view
into the application
metrics, telemetry,
then you can use
open source agents
and collect additional logs
and metrics from inside the VM
and from the application
context directly.
So if you want to troubleshoot
any application or gain
insights for
optimization or usage,
you can do it all in one place
in Google Cloud's operations.
Now, when you peek inside a
typical VMware deployment,
you're going to find that
the top workloads are often
based on databases like
SQL server and Oracle.
And typically, these are
operational transactional
databases that feed into data
warehousing infrastructures.
Often, these warehousing
infrastructures
are proprietary and expensive.
They require explicit
infrastructure management
and maintenance.
But Google provides
data services
that simplifies and
supercharges this process.
BigQuery is a serverless, highly
scalable and cost-effective
data warehouse designed to help
you turn big data into informed
business decisions.
It works seamlessly
for real-time analytics
and automatically scales
as your data scales,
so that your data continues to
make sense to you, without you
having to change your
infrastructure every time you
have a scale change.
Tools like Tableau
and Data Studio
work seamlessly with BigQuery
to help you better understand
your information.
And you can use services,
such as Cloud Dataflow,
to incrementally ingest
data, embellish it
with different sources coming
from various different systems,
clean it dynamically before it's
fed into the BigQuery system.
So you can become more
efficient, more intelligent,
and more agile
with data analysis,
and save cost while you edit it.
So as you can see, the service
enables you to not only bring
VMware to Google Cloud, but
also the services and innovation
of Google Cloud to
VMware to give you
the best of both worlds.
So now that you've seen all
the features and benefits
of running VMware
in Google Cloud,
when and where can you get it?
As you see the deployment
plan in this screen,
Google Cloud is fully
committed to make sure
that you get VMware in
the location you prefer.
We are expanding
quickly and widely.
And you should be able to
consume VMware in 10 regions
by the end of this year.
And I have to note that this
is the fastest and widest
deployment of a VMware in the
public cloud from any provider.
So to summarize, you
can see that Google
has a number of
technical advantage
that gives you a
very compelling, very
compatible and high performance
enterprise infrastructure
for your VMware environments.
The VMware service that
VMware Engine offers
is fully integrated
with Google Cloud.
It gives you the highest
level of availability
of any cloud provider.
And you get a single source
for all your VMware and cloud
needs, including support,
transaction, billing,
and so forth.
So it's a very cost-effective
and very compelling
offer that helps you supercharge
your cloud transformation
and application modernization.
So that's a wrap, folks.
If you would like
to find out more,
you can go to the
product page at
cloud.google.com/vmware-engine.
If you have any questions
for the Product team,
you can send an email to
vmware-engine@google.com.
And you can also check out other
sessions, charged with VMware
Engine experts, and also check
out a digital demo via the Next
On Air page.
With that, I thank you for
your time and attention today,
and I hope you all stay safe.
Thank you.